Kim Kardashian and Paris Hilton are
working on a secret project together The
Simple Life era is shaking Paris posted
the video with the caption secret
project with Kim Kardashian I can't stop
looking at my best friend's ass which is
the name of her new song so it's likely
something to do with that especially
because do you remember back in 2008
Paris made a comment on a radio show
saying Kim's butt looked like cottage
cheese stuffed into a trash bag yeah not
so nice she later said she was just
joking and apologized to Kim but still
they've had a rollercoaster of a
friendship throughout the years they
were friends since they were kids you
remember when Kim appeared on The Simple
Life she was organizing Paris's closets
in 2006 ish they were seen everywhere
together which is crazy because Kim back
then was just known as Paris's hot
friend they took their infamous trip to
Ibiza
that they still talked about to this day
everyone has heard about this trip what
happened on this trip and then around
2008 ish things start to unravel this is
when that radio show common happened in
2011 Paris admitted in an interview with
Harper's Bazaar that they had drifted
apart and they don't really talk but
over the past few years they've
connected on social media a few times
Kim sent Paris her fragrance they've run
into each other but pretty recently
they've been seen together a lot the
hatchet seems to be buried
Kim was that Paris's birthday party
Paris was at the kardashian Christmas
party when she and Kim went sledding
together I mean if you're going sledding
together your friends your friends the
hatchet is buried but now they're
working together in 2007 Ash Carlson is
shaking she's shaking since then Kim has
taken a pretty unexpected path she's
currently pursuing a law degree this is
a hundred percent true but in a sneak
peak of an upcoming episode of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
Kim is first of all of reading letters
from prison but she also reveals her
late father Robert Kardashian didn't
want her to go into law I told my dad
years ago that I was really into
criminal justice
he was like this will stress you out so
much you do not really want to take this
on she's a smart cookie I like her
that's all for now for the latest in
entertainment news subscribe to all
things ET I'm ash Carlson bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]